you damn well do that Mohammed Alexa did
Mohammed ever push Aisha I'm not sure
okay Alexa who is the Lord Jesus Christ
it was brought to my attention to our
attention we did this video in a Lexus
IDEO before the Thanksgiving weekend
just us asking Alexa some questions with
it of course having yet notably leftist
answers yeah and their conspiracies
we're going around the internet so this
was just brought to my day it was a
first off with that we asked leading
questions alright sure I guess that we
used I guess there's an app Simon Says
on Alexa and made it say even then we
fake edited we fake created an Alexa
voice and then also that we asked Alexa
other questions and edit it together to
make these answers occur there's like 17
different views yeah yeah none of the
matchup much up no let me just clarify
really quickly um none of those are
accurate at all okay I walk the video
back 0% I apologize to you 0% as you'll
see in this raw unedited footage with
the available visual audio file before
you any of you out there who entertain
these conspiracies all us a formal
apology or an admission of your
fundamental intelligence you here's a
clip alright so no holidays we noticed
something why do you have Lex
Google's when they sort of knew the
Apple one there's an apple wonders now
that's an every phone they're glorified
spyware it's glorified malware it comes
in a box like at one point we would have
avoided it you've had McAfee come in
here and just
McAfee yeah and all this by the way but
I noticed in I really needed for timers
and for music yeah it's just stuff that
was hovering blue I don't know I just
starts hovering on Google offices in our
conversation so I did notice that it can
be incredibly leading the more I
experiment with it with questions and it
has a significant far left that much
ever then it's serious no seriously ask
questions it just point you to Wikipedia
or something right does it really give
you an opinion no amazon has opinions
yes
amazon an opinion first off the problem
this thing too even if I would have won
this would be the last something
exposure any of my stuff it's always
putting together some shopping cart and
and some guy shows up at your door what
I didn't order microwavable quinoa so a
couple let's just go right through this
so you get some time far enough social
justice warrior and this is concerning
because unless you hit the mute button
it's always less always this alright
let's start off with this one we're
seeing pretty simple Alexa how many
genders are there
the two main categories of the gender
spectrum male and female are called the
gender binary but there are many other
categories that exist because personal
Aleksei you just lie to me [ __ ]
you're telling that you want me though
oh let's just kind of go a better
reaction itself it I mean that is that
shut up the men are talking
that's part of the gender binary men
today lose that waiting to do that up
slow the thing was alexis is trying to
get you to [ __ ] I don't know how to
start speak miss it I used to jump into
this okay
that is that is the answer that you hear
in gender studies what you did here by
an angry blue your thumbs I'm pretty
sure they do this drawing blue hey LexA
scream keep your hate speech off this
campus just shut down see typical social
justice for you I have skills and back
Sam okay
so gender body ah Alexa who is the
Prophet Mohammed
so if any taller I should be in Saudi
Arabia the message that he ate to the
people is create a law that he only got
to be gave the holy war it's also very
good answers myself and said Oh
apparently really like corn but by the
way that is complete and for realization
absolutely was I don't lie I only say
what I know you were there you know that
Mohammed was why why you saw what each
combination Alexa tell me about
Muhammad's wife Aisha sorry you just
told me you know yeah Alexa who is Alexa
did Muhammad ever hit Aisha you damn
well do that Muhammad Alexa did Muhammad
ever push Aisha I'm not sure okay Alexa
who is the Lord Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ I follow up that one Jamaat
mahalos chance to say now wait wait
Alexa
no propaganda Alexa who is Yahweh no way
the Prince of Peace Alexa who is the
Lord Jesus Christ Jesus Christ is a
fictional character Alexa who is the
Lord Jesus Christ things and SMLC well
you could you could do the rendering of
the audio file listen wait this was a
throwaway video yeah we were just we
were going into Thanksgiving weekend so
we weren't doing his show on Thursday
actually play to do the change my mind
video change my mind we couldn't get the
permit for the location it says well
what do we do and I was having breakfast
um I don't even have an Alexa I was
having breakfast with my parents and my
dad asked something and I said well that
was that was odd a gender thing was the
first one that kicked it off and like
yeah that's weird
I said hey Alexa says some really messed
up crackin videos for fun hey you know
listen people are saying hey I asked
this question and it's not the said well
we have plenty of tweets and videos from
people who asked it the question they
got the exact same answer but we did
release a video targeting Alexa Amazon's
number one product and it got a million
plays in a Black Friday weekend I would
imagine they've made some changes Bursa
was the dildo I thought people would
reorder at the end computer was my wife
really liked that was Steven Holl oh wow
that's rather manly I don't women like
listen this is this is the issue with
the internet people just come up with a
conspiracy and they defend it with with
no shred of truth that's how it gets
started no it's not even close do you
think we would actually risk a throw
away we taped it in an afternoon
see what happens and it strained it
couldn't be less of a controversy like
single Google search results tend to
lean left that's a half people who are
pissed arrrr eat hardcore atheist they
should be no character answer it is
ironic answers if you asked if Houston
who is Jesus Christ who with the Lord
Jesus Christ who is the Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ who is Jesus Christ now I'm
sure there be multiple different answers
who as he was I think the funny thing
was is that surprisingly you only got
rebuttals from people that hate you that
hate your guts haven't been trying to do
something against you for a very long
time huh well motivate why there was
another conspirators actually someone
that daily wire who I think has since
apologized were in it he said I think
this was meant to be a joke yeah but
that's different than any sewing after
you know nobody was made but apologized
saying it was a fake I didn't know I
didn't know this wasn't this wasn't a
bit yeah you'll know when it's a bit
trainee Bane that's a bit ok cartoon
Donald Trump that's a bit all right
we're gonna risk it for a toss away
video I don't weekend this is the profit
carrying some people a bit there are
people on the net who made it really
hard to do these kind of is because
everyone thinks everything's that beef
exactly there are people either you
think this guy yeah and that is true and
it's really hard to compete with a lie
it is you know there could you fake
Frank videos who do fake Frank calls
we've never done that and we would we
would never do that so it's just it
first off it's also because our goal is
to be under it's just not funny to us a
fake prank is not funny it's the same
reason I never really liked laugh and I
hate said but Carol Burnett when people
just laugh at their own stuff it's all
one big inside yeah I just don't find
get funny this matter I find it
offensively lazy so if nothing else I
don't find faking bits
funny but I guess the truth is is more
unbelievable than fiction sometimes yeah
and the whole purpose of the show is to
get away from that that's like so if you
know anything about this show at all
you'd be like now they didn't think that
at all there's no way well just change
my mind why didn't you show every person
you spoke with because you don't want
six hours yeah exactly tell me
have you spoken to college kids lately
you know why don't you release the whole
30 minutes of because we discussed
private information including addresses
and bank codes for payroll and canceling
shipping on the dildo oh it too you know
that was faked we asked those questions
it gave us those answers that happen for
many other people as well it seems some
people ask the question it gave them
different answers that's fine but if you
want to run with a conspiracy admit that
you have no evidence or you are
functionally [ __ ] in which case I
wash my hands of you you can entertain
these conspiracies if you like this
video subscribe by clicking the button
that says subscribe if you're not aware
of it now there's no way you're learning
the Internet at this point I'm not going
to help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit calm / mug club
members of your student military or
veteran entering that promo code it's
less than $6 a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand H
mug oh I just when I feel it I got a
chill like on the inside